renouant avec une tradition centenaire
le grand maître du chapitre des antonins
rabelaisien de chinon a ouvert le ban
des vendanges
cette cérémonie avait pour but le grand
maître ayant juger de la qualité et de
la maturité du raisin d'ouvrir la saison
de la récolte
la confrérie en grand costume s'étaient
réunis au château de chinon dominant les
vignobles
en ce sixième jour d'octobre corpus
christi 1971 je déclare ouvert le ban
des vendanges dans tout le vignoble
chinonais ai dit que tout vendangeurs et
gentes damoiselles devront ce rapt et de
cueillir des grades de bretons bien
mûres les transporter au pressoir et
conserver le précieux jus de la treille
qui deviendra un grand chinon 71 laisse
que les dignitaires
je vous invite à m'accompagner dans une
nuit proche où nous pourrons vérifier la
maturité du raisin
on s'arrêtait
qui tous les
les
ok
soli pardo
avant
m
chérie
satisfaction complète et bien je pense
que notre date de ban des vendanges est
une bonne date le raisin est très mûr et
nous devrions avoir cette année qu'un 71
de très haute qualité
c'est une année qui se situera
vraisemblablement avec les 69 70 ce
n'est peut-être un peu supérieure à 69
et tout de suite derrière les grandes
années récentes de 64 61 59 2 si célèbre
mémoire qu'en pensez vous monsieur ben
c'était exact commune et de dire
malheureusement nous avons eu le mois de
juin qui nous a enlevé une camp d'une
quantité énorme de raisin bien sûr bien
sûr nous n'aurons pas la quantité bien
loin de là une récolte entre le tiers et
la moitié d'une récolte normale au jour
un tiers un tiers de récolte oui c'est
dommage évidemment pour tous les
amateurs de chinon mais ils se
consoleront avec la qualité rideau de ce
panel et la qualité sera là